- [Narrator] Fertilization
is the epic story
of a single sperm facing incredible odds
to unite with an egg and
form a new human life,
it is the story of all of us.
(enigmatic music)
During sexual intercourse,
about 300 million sperm enter the vagina.
Soon afterward, millions of
them will either flow out
of the vagina or die in
its acidic environment.
However, many survive because
of the protective elements
provided in the fluid surrounding them.
Next, the sperm must
pass through the cervix,
and opening into the uterus.
Usually, it remains tightly closed,
but here the cervix is open for a few days
while the woman ovulates.
The sperm swim through the cervical mucus,
which is thinned to a
more watery consistency
for easier passage.
Once inside the cervix,
the sperm continues
swimming toward the uterus.
Though millions will die
trying to make it through the mucus,
some sperm remain behind caught
in the folds of the cervix,
but they may later continue the journey
as a backup to the first group.
Inside the uterus, muscular
uterine contractions
assist the sperm on their
journey toward the egg.
However, residents cells from
the women's immune system,
mistaking the sperm for foreign invaders,
destroy thousands more.
Next, half the sperm head
for the empty fallopian tube,
while the other half swim
toward the tube containing
the unfertilized egg.
Now, only a few thousand remain.
Inside the fallopian tube,
tiny cilia push the egg toward the uterus.
To continue, the sperm must surge
against this motion to reach the egg,
some sperm get trapped
in the cilia and die.
During this part of the journey,
chemicals in the reproductive
tract cause the membranes
covering the heads of the sperm to change.
As a result, the sperm become hyperactive,
swimming harder and faster
toward their destination.
At long last, the sperm reach the egg.
Only a few dozen of the original
300 million sperm remain.
The egg is covered with a layer of cells
called the corona radiata.
The sperm must push through this layer
to reach the outer layer of
the egg, the zona pellucida.
When sperm reach the zona
pellucida, they're attached
to specialized sperm
receptors on the surface
which triggers their acrosomes
to release digestive enzymes,
enabling the sperm to
burrow into the layer.
Inside de zona pellucida is
a narrow, fluid-filled space
just outside the egg cell membrane.
The first sperm to make
contact will fertilize the egg.
After a perilous journey
and against incredible odds,
a single sperm attaches
to the egg cell membrane.
Within a few minutes,
the outer membranes fuse,
and the egg pulls the sperm inside.
This event causes changes
in the egg membrane
that prevent other sperm
from attaching to it.
Next, the egg releases chemicals
that push other sperm away from the egg,
and create an impenetrable
fertilization membrane.
As the reaction spreads outward,
the zona pellucida hardens
trapping any sperm unlucky
enough to be caught inside.
Outside the egg, sperm are no longer able
to attach to the zona pellucida.
Meanwhile, inside the egg,
the tightly-packed male
genetic material spreads out.
A new membrane forms
around the genetic material
creating the male pronucleus.
Inside, the genetic material
reforms into 23 chromosomes.
The female genetic material,
awakened by the fusion of
the sperm with the egg,
finishes dividing resulting
in the female pronucleus
which also contains 23 chromosomes.
As the male and female pronuclei form,
spider-web-like threads
called microtubules
pull them toward each other.
The two sets of chromosomes join together
completing the process of fertilization.
At this moment, a unique
genetic code arises,
instantly determining gender, hair color,
eye color, and hundreds
of other characteristics.
This new single cell, the zygote,
is the beginning of a new human being.
And now the cilia and the fallopian tube
gently sweep the zygote toward the uterus
where he or she will implant
in the rich uterine lining.
Growing and maturing
for the next nine months
until ready for birth.
(enigmatic music)